la popularité de giuseppe compter dans
les sondages ne l'empêchera pas de
rendre des comptes devant la justice
italienne
le chef du gouvernement ainsi que ses
ministres de la santé de l'intérieur
vont devoir s'expliquer sur emplois en
particulier les retards constatés dans
la création d'une zone rouge comprenant
deux localités particulièrement touché
par le coronavirus même bros et alsano
lombardo dans le nord du pays fin
février le gouvernement italien décidé
en effet de confier une dizaine de
municipalités en lombardie
mais ces mesures ne concernaient pas ces
deux communes malgré les mises en garde
des experts
après de nouvelles consultations du cp
compter signe finalement un décret qui
place tout l'état lire en zone rouge le
9 mars
à l'heure du bilan le gouvernement
central et les dirigeants de la
lombardie se rejettent la responsabilité
de ce délai un confinement tardif qui
pourrait avoir entraîné la saturation du
système sanitaire lombard et une large
propagation du virus
face à la polémique et aux possibles
conséquences judiciaires
giuseppe comptait se dit serein je ne
suis pas du tout inquiet ce n'est pas
une attitude arrogante ou supérieur je
ne commenterai pas les propos du
procureur qui ont été communiqués à
l'avant sur la rai télévision nous
comparerons nous donner ce vendredi je
ferai un rapport sur tous les faits que
je connais calmement cette enquête qui
vise le pouvoir politique italien
s'ajoute un recours collectif introduit
à bergame
une cinquantaine de plaintes contre x
ont été déposées par des proches de
victimes du virus
pour ces familles endeuillées il s'agit
d'établir des responsabilités dans cette
crise il s'agit de la première étape
nous avons réalisé concrètement ce qui
jusqu'à aujourd'hui était limité à
internet
tout a commencé avec un groupe facebook
que j'ai créé avec mon père le 22 mars
pour voir s'il y avait d'autres
personnes qui voulaient raconter leur
histoire qui à leurs yeux comportait des
zones d'ombré nous voulons la vérité
comprendre ce qui s'est passé et
recevoir justice
celui qui a fait une erreur il est juste
qu'il paye pour cela selon les agences
de presse italiennes
les magistrats pourraient entendre le
chef du gouvernement dès ce vendredi 12
jours à rome